ladies and Gentlemen please welcome
Peter
Lee wow so uh it's really always great
to see this place filled like this uh so
I'm Peter Lee and welcome uh to our 15th
annual Microsoft research faculty
Summit this is a really significant
event for us one one reason that feels
that makes this year feel particularly
special is the sense that in our
community in our community as
researchers particularly in Computing uh
but also in related fields there's a
sense that I have and I think that many
of us share uh that we are really on the
verge of some very exciting developments
and maybe even breakthroughs in a number
of
subfields and what is really great for
for us in Microsoft research is that so
many of these subfields and so many of
the areas that seem to be making such
amazing progress today also seem to
align so perfectly with where the tech
industry is going and in particular
where Microsoft is going and so all of
that together just gives us a sense of
real what I call exhilaration
exhilaration meaning this combination of
incredible joy and opportunity in the
research work that we do as well as some
Terror because we really feel Under
Pressure to deliver and so I'm hoping
through this factly something that
you'll get some sense about
that now um talking about Microsoft uh
the last year has been a year of
tremendous change and I suspect uh
through the next uh couple of days uh
many of you will get some sense of the
kinds of changes the kinds of turbulence
and the kinds of new opportunities uh
that are emerging in Microsoft uh and
Microsoft research uh we have for
example completely new leadership we
have a new CEO in SAA nadela uh I'm
actually new uh in this role only uh in
this role as head of Microsoft research
for only about a year uh and uh we have
a new Executive Vice President for
technology and
research my b and a member of the senior
leadership team for this company Harry
sham our keynote speaker this
morning now uh Harry I believe will try
to convey to you in more concrete terms
some of the reasons why we're so excited
and also why it's so important for us to
be engaging with you in as productive
and as fun manner as possible um I
recently did uh informal audit of all of
the research activities going on in
Microsoft research and over 80% of the
research that we do in MSR worldwide is
done in collaboration with you with
members of the academic Community we
host over 12200 PhD student interns in
our Labs every year that's a tremendous
tremendous thing for us um and we hope
it's also a great benefit to to your
research uh programs as well and of of
course we have hundreds of visiting
faculty members uh in all of our Labs
every year it is an incredible magnifier
uh for what we do and it really helps
ground us in the real reality of what's
emerging in Computing research today and
bring that into
Microsoft so thank you for all that and
thank you for being here uh your
presence here uh really honors us um and
is something that uh that we really
treasure and so now let me uh introduce
Harry sh
Harry is our new Executive Vice
President actually appointed last
November midst all of the changes in the
top leadership of this company uh Harry
is someone who's just very near and dear
to all of us in Microsoft research uh
Harry finished his PhD at carneg Mel
University in
1996 um and after a couple of stints in
other places joined Microsoft research
and became very quickly uh an important
uh world researcher in computer vision
and related fields uh and in fact has a
number of seminal contributions to his
credit um he then uh went to Beijing uh
and took over the directorship of our
lab uh in Asia Microsoft research Asia
uh and really brought that lab to
worldwide prominence uh and established
uh uh kind of habit of Excellence uh in
that part of the world as well as deeply
engaging with academic Community
throughout all of Asia
then he was sent off to War uh to wage
one of the biggest battles in the tech
industry uh to run all of engineering
for Bing and really took us into a
prominent Place uh to the point where we
have a search engine and in fact a
substrate for web uh intelligence uh
that in the future is going to really
power uh so much of what Microsoft tries
to do and so with Harry we have this
incredible technical depth and research
credibility as well as the street
credibility in the tech industry uh that
is truly rare um it's a little weird for
me to be uh uh to have as a boss someone
who is so accomplished but also someone
who was a student at the time I was a
professor at Carnegie melon um makes one
feel old um but as long as I'm humble
about it I think it all goes okay um so
with that um please give a warm welcome
to uh Executive Vice President for
technology and research Dr Harry
sham thank you very
much thank you very much Professor Lee
uh
uh I I think someday we all work for
people who are younger and uh think
about the B Gates and
Zuckerberg it it's really a great uh
pleasure and really uh quite humbling
for me uh to give this keynote speech
thanks to Peter and the Janette for
inviting me to give this talk um I
actually would like to start my
presentation by thanking a lot of people
uh uh because that's actually where uh
know how we actually got here I really
want to start by thanking Rick Rashid uh
I should say Professor Rashid uh for
starting Microsoft research 23 years ago
with his vision and with his leadership
you know uh that's why we actually got
this far uh Rick has been instrumental
in a number of ways uh uh not to mention
the fact that he actually kicked me out
of research seven years ago and two
product team thank you Rick uh then I
also want to thank in the Pete and the
Janette for doing a wonderful job on
last few years uh leading Microsoft uh
to the new height uh actually not only
uh Rick is Professor Rashid p is
Professor Lee actually is also Professor
Wing uh of mine and uh uh I I will try
to be a good
student I want to have a special thanks
to Tony hay uh for leading uh MSR
connections over last several years uh
Tony has been uh doing such a great job
uh connecting Microsoft research with
the the broad academic and scientific
Community as as Peter said it's
incredibly important for us to have this
close relationship with the Academia and
with scientific Community uh if you look
at all those advancements in our Fields
uh even in other scientific fields in
other Industries uh it is because of the
basic research that led a lot of
Innovations in the godess this far uh
with Tony mve into a different role and
I'm very pleased to welcome uh anandan
to this new role of uh leading MSR
Outreach
um an of course has a lot of great
credentials not only he was a professor
before and he worked in other Industrial
Research Labs before he actually moved
to uh Microsoft research 16 17 years ago
uh then and then moved to India to uh
really F our India lab in Bangalore for
the last 10 years he has been leading
the the lab there um I really want to
make a joke please laugh and an is very
handsome
yeah
so thank you Ed so
uh it's very exciting time for Microsoft
it's really very very exciting time for
Microsoft Peter said that we announced
our new CEO Sati and adala in January uh
Sati is only the third CEO in the
history of Microsoft uh for the last 38
years uh thinking about that this is a
lot of tradition you know over the years
years in saia's inauguration speech he
made it very clear the most important
thing for this company I this sounds
almost too rhetoric it's it's all about
Innovation it doesn't really matter how
successful we have been over the last
the four decades with Windows and the
office in particular it really doesn't
matter anymore it's really about you
know do we have the next big things do
we have the Innovation that will carry
Microsoft Corporation for the next
decades next few decades and Beyond it
actually give us uh Microsoft research
uh this great opportunity to show a lot
of thought leadership and really to show
a lot of leadership and the overall to
work with the rest of the company to
really think about you know what does
this even mean you know Innovation and
what does this mean for Microsoft
researchers and for our
organization last Thursday SAA sent an
email to the entire company
outline his overall strategy and where
the company is heading and in his email
he said in his memo he said very clearly
at our core Microsoft is the platform
and the productivity company and we will
go mobile first and the cloud first now
I want to explain this a little bit what
does this really
mean well most of you know realize and
recognize Microsoft as the the windows
and the office company
and not too long ago you know Windows
was everywhere and know you could even
think about you know Windows probably
was on the 90% of the Computing devices
out there but the world is evolving
there are just more and more devices out
there there are different plat platforms
emerging so we will make it very clear
that we go crossplatform if you missed
it and let me just point out a couple of
things actually Sati announced after he
took the CEO role
s announced that for office we will go
to iOS platform so for those of you who
do use iPad you can actually get an
Office for iPad on your devices and six
days after that announcement Saia also
announced that windows will be free for
any devices that's actually uh smaller
than 9 Ines I actually recently had a
chance to visit the sing and the Taiwan
where a lot of Hardware manufacturing
Happ happening there and one very
interesting phenomena actually I noticed
when I talked to those Hardware
manufacturers is that they were very
excited talking to me about the new sexy
device they're making the 8.9
inin I said that give you a better idea
why do you make it 8.99 in
St and as we move forward and we
actually know must have a world view we
we need to be realistic and we need to
be aspirational as we move forward we
need to understand that you know where
the industry is moving where our company
is today and where our company is going
to move to that's really a lot of things
that MSR can play such a key role and uh
also you know that's where we can really
work together with that the all of you
in Academia to think about you know
where we're actually heading so there
are couple of things I want to share
with you at least you know how we
actually have been thinking
about the future in MSR and in Microsoft
Corporation I actually feel extremely
excited about the future for our
industry especially in terms of the
number number of devices popping up if
you think about today we probably have
you know 300 million PCS every year and
we probably have close to three billion
you know mobile phones now actually
manufactured every year as you continue
to think about
it's not difficult to project that there
is another OD of magnitude of those
little Computing devices especially with
sensing capability whether they are on
your body and know whether actually on
the in the room and in your home in
workplace you know on airplanes and
everywhere it's easy for me to at least
to think about that in know senses
everywhere uh we actually uh have an
design Expo showing the later uh I
strongly encourage you to go take a look
at that we have uh H uh nine
universities and their students here
showing some very interesting things you
know know what will this world be know
if we actually have a billion census
everywhere uh even so you know I believe
it will be know 10 billions 100 billions
you know very soon but I think it's
interesting to look at those ideas those
students coming up and uh it's just very
very exciting you will see a lot of
interesting projects from Microsoft as
well well I think Desy is going to talk
about a lot of medical sensors uh you
know why this actually matters to our
society and the ubiquitous Computing is
also happening it's just the devices
just all those Computing devices are
just becoming really ubiquitous
everywhere I tell you a
story uh recently a few months ago we
actually at in our home we actually
Chang the home router and uh as my wife
and I were installing the new rou OU and
then we realize that you know the we
actually have 27 Computing devices
actually from our house our house is is
not a typical house probably you know I
do have a number of uh but we don't only
have three people at home now you know
it's just my wife and me and our younger
boy so so I was asking my wife I said
really we actually have 20 27 27 devices
and then I realized that I I have five
phones and number of tablets and all
those and then you have some old devices
you even forgot to delete from your
router and I just think about that it's
probably there's a very interesting
number in know we can let's keep in mind
is what I call the the from 5 to1 to1
125 not too many years ago there was
only one PC in a family of five so
that's actually 5 to1 and nowaday I
think we really moving towards you know
each individual might even have five
different devices now now the question
for computer scientists is you know what
are you going to do with your five
devices besides in just the wasting
energy it's really it's really the case
you know most of the time it's just
lying around and not doing anything I
think there a lot of you know the system
projects can be done and uh so something
for us to think about the last one I
want to point out is very very exciting
is what Saia calls ambient intelligence
and with sensus everywhere with
ubiquitous Computing it's actually
pretty straightforward in my mind that's
is the the the Computing Paradigm is
Shifting it's really shifting from the
personal computers of the past to
personal Computing of the future and the
present by personal Computing I'm really
saying I think the user is now at the
center you know what is the most scarce
resources nowaday if you think about
everything you know in this kind of
computing environment it's really no
longer the computing power it's no
longer even storage no longer even even
the bangu it is really people's time it
is people's attention I think that is
where a lot of money can be made a lot
of Innovations can be done a lot of very
exciting research you know should happen
I think this is uh some overall view you
know how we think about in Microsoft and
just think about know now why did you
want to have those wears you actually
you know have with you in the end it's
actually about the data in the end it's
about the sensing in the end about the
contextual information all the sensors
can provide that hopefully with powerful
algorithms and the software we actually
can reason about and do something
interesting so what should we do in this
new era what should Microsoft research
be doing well I would
say 23 years ago Rick already outlined
his vision about you know Microsoft
research mission statement all I need to
do you know together with pet the Jette
is slightly modify it so R always said
that we should first of all do World
worldclass research absolutely and we
should have product impact especially by
doing technology transfers into existing
products I said
absolutely and Rick always said that you
know we should really do you know great
things to make sure that the Microsoft
and the Microsoft products have a future
I will just elaborate at a little bit
you know details I think in this new era
what we should really do I think we
should continue to do wonderful
worldclass research and I think for sure
and collaboration with all of you in
Academia in terms of product impacts I
think we have done really well as I said
that P and gen continue to do great work
you know in moving a lot of you know
great Technologies into our products I'm
actually going to show you some examples
very soon but we need to think even
bigger we should really think about that
it's not only the the the Technologies
we already done you know through you
know basic research we should
thoughtfully pick you know projects that
we actually have a view We Believe those
things will be big and uh we start from
there then thinking about what are those
big shifts if you look back at the
history of our industry I would say
there were probably four you know big
technology trends that happened in the
last 15 20 years and I would also
proudly say that MSR actually saw most
of those Trends coming with our
researchers work I would say this is
mobile phone there's a tablet and
there's search and there's Cloud if you
look at that I would say well we
actually started mobile phone probably
early than anyone else we did tablet PC
before people even thought tablet was
interesting and I would also say we
always thought about the cloud because
we actually have server business you
know we kind of struggled in search you
know whether this is a commodity whether
this is a business model you know
whether is actually interesting enough
you know research work out there I think
if we look at the history and if we
think about the future we just say what
what are the next big things what are
the next big weaves that we at MSR
should identify and lock on those things
show a lot of thought leadership and
pushes the company towards that
direction I actually feel very confident
that we have the opportunity we have our
chances because it's all starts with
great people and we have great people in
Microsoft research and great with great
minds uh I'm just so pleased to see
lesie lampor winning this year's tying
award we actually had a great showing in
the very large group of Microsoft people
at the ACM award ceremony we're so happy
to see Leslie winning teing award uh
it's long overdue in my opinion
uh especially I would say Les Le is
winning just I just I just personally
feel so happy for Leslie uh if nothing
else I would say you know I used his
software to write the most of my papers
I suspect that is true for most of you
as well and there was Leslie winning
touring now he actually is the fifth
person in Microsoft research winning
touring award and I worry that we
actually have to uh have more parking
spots for all our touring Award winners
by the way this is not a Photoshop just
so you understand this is real and uh at
this tough economic time we probably
cannot give Ley too much cash bonus but
at least we can give uh him a parking
spots uh it also very inspiring I would
say you know for our younger generation
researchers someday you know if you can
get the reserve the parking spot just so
know you understand that you know not
any company executive actually reserve
the parking spot you know it's only it's
only IQ matters
so so not only we actually feel
confident that we actually have great
minds within our team today and we are
also you know trying really hard and
confident in recruiting new talents and
I'm very pleased uh to let you know that
President McAfee recently uh joined us
as Microsoft's new Chief Economist and
the president will actually work very
closely with me and more importantly
with our CFO Amy and the the the
business and the engineering leaders uh
to focus on at this time and age you
know how should we really know think
about Microsoft's new business model you
know anything from the premium to other
things uh pricing strategy a lot of very
exciting things pron uh Preston as some
of you might know you know used to be a
faculty member at the ctech but for the
last seven years he has been working in
our industry you know working previously
in um know some other internet companies
so we're very very pleased to have
President join us and as our chief
Economist and I think he might be here
and you you might have a chance to see
him during the faculty Summit so so that
actually leads me to uh my next session
about you know what we actually work
what actually uh we are working on in
Microsoft research some of those
exciting uh research
areas uh we actually have been working
on uh the area of economics and the
special economics and the computation
for quite a while thanks to Jennifer
Chase's leadership we actually have
hired a small group of economists in our
uh Boston lab and New York New York lab
uh I had the chance to go to the ec14
conference it's the first time I
actually attended in the uh uh as pet
said I used to do Vision in the graphics
so this is actually very new for me so
so it's just so exciting to see those
economists theoretical computer
scientists those algorithm people coming
together talking about uh Anonymous
currencies Bitcoin and and Bitcoins
Bitcoins and some other very interesting
things you know auction pricing uh you
know my mind my head was spinning but it
was really exciting to learn from those
people and the the good thing about the
economists is actually they look at data
and then they have some fun with it and
for example they do forecasting so we
recently I had some fun in the with
World Cup um so I actually feel sorry
for myself I'm actually massive fan but
I'm happy for Germany to win they are
really a better team and in the end is
the better team wins so if you look at
that uh the this website actually said
that you know with Germany's winning
today Microsoft perfectly predicted the
World Cup's knockout run it's actually
not entirely true uh that's actually
ignoring the Brazil Netherland game but
no one thought that his knockout wrong
anyway so that's probably also true so
so the next area I want to share with
you is actually Quantum Computing and I
I I just uh it's really humbling for me
to know have a chance to come back to
MSR to learn from so many great people
especially in those areas I don't
understand uh just because I actually
visit the Michael fredman's team in
Santa Barbara really doesn't mean I
actually know a lot about about Quantum
Computing I can give you a few Buzz was
but that's pretty much it but it's very
very exciting to see Quantum Computing
mve to the more and more prominent stage
I want to thank Craig Mandi for having
the vision and the leadership to really
start the quantum Computing work and we
have been making tremendous investment
over the last decade and we're very very
lucky to have Michael fredman leads the
effort uh if you uh haven't had a chance
to look at the John markov's article uh
in New York time I strongly recommend
that you know you must use Bing to find
this article it's actually easier uh to
get this
uh so the one thing is very special
about you know Microsoft's effort on
Quantum Computing is is really how broad
we look at this problem you know we we
work with the theory people we work with
the experiment list and we also you know
think about the the quantum algorithms
and the more and the more we also really
bet on the software architectures and
how we actually have a chance someday
someday soon to really build quantum
computers that will make difference
uh you will hear exciting progress uh
from Christa in the next session uh it's
it's it's really really cool
stuff uh the third area and the last
area I I want to mention this morning is
actually hardware and Hardware of course
is very broad you know from Little
devices to the making PCS to making
tablets to networking gears and
everything you know is about hardware
and we do a lot of Hardware stuff and
you know we build a little sensus here
and and we also have done some really
really know breakthrough technology
recently and in collaboration with the B
team is actually on the fpga and the
programmable
Hardware uh it was actually uh
recognized not only by the academic
Publications but also by the popular
press uh I want to show you a a short
video uh really talking about you know
what we actually have been using uh fpgs
to boost the performance and the saving
cost for our data
centers in late 2010 Jim Lis and I MSR
had an idea that we thought could give
Bing a huge boost in capabilities we
really asked two fundamental questions
first what could we build that would
give Microsoft the best data center
infrastructure in the industry secondly
we asked what could we build that would
provide us some insurance against the
looming end of Mo's law this is the
windows Cloud Server we didn't want to
disrupt the design of the standard
server so we had to work with this tiny
space up here in the corner and what
we've designed to fit there is this
catapult board with 8 GB of RAM PCI
Express gen 3 and we've networked all of
these together into a custom 6x8 Taurus
to create a reconfigurable fabric of
fpgas so we can effectively replace an
entire server with just one of these
little cards the implications are
enormous if we take into account all the
other scenarios that light up at data
center scale which is why Bing is moving
forward with deploying catapult into
production in one of our data centers in
2015 so it's actually a good transition
also into the next session I want to
talk about is actually you know how
Microsoft research has been making great
product impacts the doc project you the
is really a collaboration with the Bing
team actually I was at the Bing team at
that time
uh you got to realize that no when you
work in products you actually have
deadlines you have a lot of constraints
talking about having a different skill
and a different kind of you know the the
the server setup in a large data center
with special components is a huge
challenge for the engineering team
because what if something wrong and what
if you actually have to take those
servers off so it took the product team
a lot of guts to collaborate with Doc's
team of course with huge commitment from
dog and his team you know we really
worked very closely together and if I
look at you know where know it is today
you know compared with two three years
ago when we started it's a tremendous
progress there uh I think this is really
just the beginning uh you will hear more
from Doc in the next session uh it is
becoming a hot Trend and uh uh we're
very very excited about the potential
there talking about the making product
impact the one thing we actually have is
really the luxury at Microsoft because
of the the broad scope know of all kinds
of products and the software products
and the services that we at Microsoft
deliver to know hundreds of millions if
not billions of users and one of the the
the most popular software we have in
this company is of course
office and office is also a product
where we can have a lot more Innovation
the innovation today you know where the
cloud first and the mobile first we
really have the opportunity there I'm
sure you know you use a lot of uh
Microsoft software especially
PowerPoints for the professors and The
Graduate students you know we do a lot
of presentations and the Powerpoints
until now is still a dominating
presentation software but the one thing
you know with PowerPoint is actually
it's really not that you know
interactive you know it's actually nice
animation and everything but everything
you you you actually design and put up
there and by the time you do the
presentation is just very difficult to
change anything so Ana from Microsoft
research you know has thought about this
problem law on the heart you know came
up with a lot of interesting ideas and
can you think about you know how can you
interact with the audience you know
after you actually have your PowerPoint
Without Really changing much about your
PowerPoint at all you know how can we
add on those interactive elements to
make it actually more interesting and
more interactive more exciting with the
audience and an is actually going to
have in a short presentation I think
with Andy this afternoon and he will
have more details talking to you about
this uh it's a new product and uh at no
cost and something that I strongly
encourage you to give it a
try the second area and I want to talk
about is actually uh Skype uh Skype
continues to be the dominating uh uh
communication software you know on the
net on the on the web
uh we recently have worked very closely
with the uh Skype team to really
incorporate the great machine
translation technology especially speech
to speech translation uh into the
product uh many of you have seen Rick's
wonderful demo uh Speech to speech a
couple of years ago I believe in the
first uh he showed that in China uh with
the Chinese and English
translation uh we actually extend that
to multiple languages and uh we make
this the reality we ship this product so
let me show you a short video uh what it
looks
like hello Diana how's it going hello is
Diana V hello
my hello my friend you are soon going we
want our Technologies to enable people
around the world to work better together
it is so hard for us to become
multilingual
but we now are on the verge of having a
tool that allows us to speak universally
with anyone on the
planet but on the weekend I was always
in London I think my family would love
it there this summer but I'm sure my
kids will find it hard to leave their
friends in Seattle
think
if we can you know test it out a little
bit in order to make this technology
work we had to invest in over a decade
of research little ideas and a little
bit deeper knowledge buils up over time
we eventually get to a point where
wonderful things can happen the Indian
food is
great what brings you to London well
with a Skype translator you get to see
the facial expressions of the person
you're conversing with you get a sense
of that person's body language and now
on top of that you have the magic of
understanding what that person is saying
and having that person understand what
you're saying it's truly a magical
experience how nice I hope you have a
good trip it's been great talking to you
I'll do in
cheers so I I really hope that you know
we will have this product out very soon
and many of you can give it a try and
give us feedback
uh is is it's it's really really
exciting and uh I cannot overstate the
the importance know for people to have
the ability to communicate in across
language uh uh barriers and uh some of
us actually had to learn English you
know you can easily imagine that so the
the last uh uh product impact example I
want to show you is actually uh with a
new product we called Catana Catana is
actually the personal uh assist digital
personal assistant um that can
understand you about you know what's
going on in your daily life your work
and you know what we can really help you
uh you might have heard you know some
other competing products out there in
the industry and from uh Apple Siri to
Google now uh you should really give a
Kotana a try if you have a Windows phone
today uh the all the the product reviews
I have read uh um said it really well
you know that the as of now you know k
is actually out of Performing the
competing products you know in the
market uh to help me out I'm going to
invite my colleague uh daring ID to come
up to show you some demo and especially
with some latest research results you
know how we can help you and as a
researcher as a professor and for your
research work Darren please thank you
har hello everyone I'm here today to
show you folks some interesting work our
team's been doing around academic search
which I'm sure is a near and dear
Pastime for a lot of you folks here
today so our team set out with a pretty
ambitious goal we want to create the
world's most powerful digital research
assistant so I know what a lot of you
might be thinking is it's a pretty tall
order pretty hard thing to achieve right
but we think Microsoft is uniquely
positioned to succeed here for a number
of different reasons first we have
Microsoft academic search which while an
old site is still a rich source of
academic data next we have B which is
Microsoft's world class search engine
and finally we have Cartana which is
Microsoft's new personal assistant
shipping on Windows
phone so when we combine these
Technologies we think we have the
opportunity to create some pretty
amazing research assistance
scenarios but before I jump into those
scenarios I want to give you folks a
quick preview of Catana I think she's
new enough that most of you might not
know what she's capable
of so
excuse me if you have a Windows Phone
Cortana is your personal assistant she's
there to help you when you need it and
keeps you up to date on things that
matter the most to you and like any good
personal assistant she's great at
answering questions for
example what will the weather be like
today so as you can see Sunny so welcome
to Seattle folks you picked the perfect
time of year to come um even though it's
actually a bit harder bit hotter than I
would normally like um so you know this
is not really a hard question you know
any modern search engine can answer this
without breaking a sweat where things
start getting a little bit more
interesting though is when you start
telling Cortana about yourself so for
this let me go back to cortana's home
screen and click on our notebook up in
the upper right hand corner here so this
is where Cortana keeps everything she
knows about you so you can see I've
added a couple things here for example
where I live and where I work and also
the fact that I like the Mariners for
those of you who don't know that's a a
local baseball team that hopefully some
of you are fans of
um she uses this data this information
to enable some pretty cool scenarios so
for example remind
me remind me to call my wife when I
leave work
today oh she picked up the first one
let's try this one more time remind me
to call my wife when I leave work
today
so as you can see here she has no
problems recognizing the task I'm trying
to complete but beyond that she also
uses what she knows about you to build a
proactive snapshot what's important for
example you can see if I go to her home
screen she actually has the Mariner
schedule up there for me to look at you
know while this is Excuse me while this
is you know pretty cool it still begs
the question how do we transform Katana
into an actual research assistant you
know research being the key word there
so let me try doing something very
simple I want to research one of my
colleagues udong see how C does with
this one
udong so she didn't get the name right
unfortunately so this you know doesn't
help me too much you know finding out
about my colleague and you know to be
fair if you try this same exact task
with Siri or Google now you'll get very
similar results and this isn't because
speech recognition isn't ready for the
prime time in fact there's been a ton of
Innovations made in the past few years
accuracy with Microsoft research
actually contributing a lot um but you
know despite these Innovations there are
there still a lot of hard problems in
front of us to make a truly useful
research
assistant so for example for a research
assistant to be truly useful she need to
not she need to understand not just the
common phrases but the uncommon phrases
as well so for this I'm going to bring
my other phone online here so on the
left here you'll see the current Cartana
but on the right here this is actually
the new research kartent that we've been
we've been building so let me try the
same query
again you
dong so you see on the left here we have
basically the same result well different
different different REO obviously but
similar not useful results um but if you
look at the left or sorry at the right
you seey to actually recognize the
person I was trying to talk about and
trying to you know research and this is
a really hard problem you know to set
some context currently Cartana lexicon
or number of words you can understand
numbers around a million you know while
they may seem like a lot it really only
helps her answer some of the more common
phrases but our team has actually
developed a method that increases the
size of this lexicon to over a billion
words that's that's huge that allows us
to you know nail these uncommon phrases
really easily in addition to that even
do mixed language queries but let me set
the speech stuff aside for one second
and move on to uh digging to my friend
yudong here so for this for the rest of
this demo I want you to pretend I'm Quan
song who's my boss um because
unfortunately I personally don't have
much of a presence in the academic world
which will be important for this next
part so let's go ahead and click on Yong
here and you can see that beinging which
is withth powering this actually has a
deep understanding of his academic
profile so for example I can see his
most impactful papers impactful papers
that have cited his work who he most
frequently co-authors with and also and
this is really cool how him and I are
related in this case you can see that
I've co-authored a paper with someone
who in turn has co-authored with
Yong and this relationship you're
looking at
here is really really important and we
make some amazing uses of it inside
kartana's understanding of research so
for example if I go back to kartana's
home
screen you can see that she well first
of all recognizes the fact that I'm at
the Microsoft facult Su today which um
call back to the ambient understanding
or ambient intelligence thing there is
actually pretty cool in of itself beyond
that you can see she's suggested a
couple events that I should go attend
based on my relationships with the
presenters so in this case let's go
ahead and click on leang to see why
Cortana is recommending I attend this
event in this case you can see that I've
directly co-authored a paper with Lee
Deng which is a very strong signal for
her to
consume but beyond that we're also
extending cortana's notebook to allow
her to build a better understanding of
your academic interest so let's go back
to cortana's home screen for a second
here go to our
notebook and let's try adding a new
interest you'll see now that we have a
new category for academic here when we
click on this you'll see that she's
actually suggested a couple things that
I might be interested in in this case I
in fact very passionate about machine
learning so let's go ahead and click on
that you'll see that she's now added
that interest to her uh to her notebook
in a new section for academic interests
and she makes you know immediate use of
this information as well so when you go
back to our home screen you can now see
that the faculty Summit has two new
events I should attend based on my
interest in machine
learning
so in
conclusion I think a question a lot of
you folks might be wondering is great
when can I use this it's pretty cool
well our team is actually has has a
pretty aggressive timeline we want to
make this available on both being in
Cortana early next year um but before
that we actually have a call to action
for everyone in the audience today we
would like you to go to the site um or
scan it with your phone whichever works
best for you and tell us a bit about
yourself in your academic career uh and
it's we're going to use this data as a
pretty important strong signal for us to
build like really amazing research
assistant so hopefully see you folks
using this early next year har back to
you thank you Darren thanks
yeah so we we actually very excited
about the Catana and uh the one thing I
would really want to point out the the
why quana is becoming so important uh as
you think about that the world is really
moving you know from the the more and
the more the web to the apps and at the
web time you could think about you know
maybe search is the entry point to the
web and uh now you know with all those
mobile devices then you just populate
every mobile device populated with you
know hundreds if not more apps there
it's actually very very difficult to
really navigate through all the apps and
the apps actually also very difficult to
index is the one way to really get there
is actually through this kind of natural
interaction with the user and by
understanding all the contents and all
those apps so we're really excited about
you know the where Katana is heading as
a product and as a service and we think
that you know for the academic Community
we can work together really think about
you know how can we make Katana also a
great research assistant as
well so the final segments of my
presentation I really want to you know
hypothesize a few things as we talk
about you know next big things and it's
really it's really very early and uh no
does not really mean that those few
things I pick here are absolutely the
next big things that we will you know
put all the efforts at MSR there but we
have to have a view we have to have a
view Clearly say we see where that world
is moving to and we believe MSR can do
all those great things together with our
product teams and we can take to the
next level the first thing I really want
to you know come back to in the earlier
slides you know we talked about you know
the census everywhere and the ubiquitous
Computing and the ambient intelligence I
really start with the the sensors uh
people now they talk about internet of
things and all those uh I really want to
emphasize the the the the sensing s side
because all those little devices what do
they
do eventually they start as some kind of
a2d device they actually sense something
you know perceive something in the
environment or you know perceive
something about your body and get some
data and then you upload the data
somewhere then you aggregate then you
make some sense out of that uh the
project we actually uh started last
year's uh a very exciting project I want
to point out here is the uh this project
called lab of things uh it's not only
about the the device and the sensors we
buil it's really about you know how you
put those things together you know with
the apis that we support especially you
know with the academic Community how we
can work together uh it's really nice
piece of work uh MSR and the universal
of Maryland work together I want to roll
a short video and tell you what we have
been doing
the lab of things by the very nature of
this design of the platform allows you
to innovate quickly it allows you to
test out a design it tests out your
ideas very quickly in real environments
collect data and then see if your design
is working or not working which is a
very big motivation for Innovation we
are developing uh textile based
capacitive sensors that could be built
into clothing bed sheets pillow covers
and even wheelchair pads so the idea
here is to use these sensors as
proximity sensors to detect gestures for
people with paralysis so people with
paralyses can use these gestures for
controlling the environment whether it's
lights switches televisions U making a
911 call or even making a nurse call lab
of things essentially provides the
software framework on top of which we
have built the data collection unit data
processing unit and gesture detection
unit My Hope for this project is with
this technology to have folks that have
injuries such as quadriplegics or other
types of impairments of their maybe
upper extremities to be able to be more
independent to have the confidence that
they don't have to rely on someone all
the time this way they can live their
life as normal as possible and to be
able to just get out have fun and enjoy
life talking about uh uh sensors and
little device I want to show you a
little uh small camera that we actually
are building in Microsoft research and
uh it's actually a uh low power always
on little camera you can actually put
you know anywhere you want you know with
you and as you move around uh you could
take a lot of pictures many of you
actually remember uh my life bits
project and the garden Bell started and
uh I think it's a really great vision
and we actually can take that to the
next level by really you know deploying
this kind of devices and uh so I want to
show you a a a video clip uh that
actually uh I recently uh walked around
Seattle with the camera and uh then I
show you know what we are going to do is
the the huge amount of data we actually
uh have so let me just show you the the
the the the little bit as a video clip
here so now you immediately see the
problem and just walking around and the
the the the video is actually so video
is actually jaggy and so so what did you
do you know as a vision guy I would just
say well we should do video
stabilization and synthesiz a new video
sequence here uh this is actually the
the new uh video results you know
produced by our Vision
Group if we slow down the speed it
actually will look even more smooth so
it's a really nice result and
uh I I should really understand how that
was done and uh except that I was kicked
out of research seven years ago I forgot
all the computer vision computer vision
stuff so so I thought maybe I just get
some help you know uh from my colleague
uh Dan so I invited then come up here
and do a close remote collaboration with
me then I really need to learn something
from you man and what is this Vision
stuff that looks really cool you know
well thank you Harry let's see if we can
get an introduction to this thank you
everybody for uh having patience as we
watch Harry bike around Seattle today so
uh
Harry can we share a session what we're
showing here is a new research system
called vboard which allows real-time
collaboration amongst people who are
actually separated we're here on the
same stage but you can imagine that we
are in different parts of the world and
we want to communicate
together so with this system using
connect sensor it can it can place me
into the scene with Harry and I can see
Harry I'm not actually going to look at
the real Harry I'm going to look at the
digital Harry and I feel like he is part
of the meeting that we are you look you
look really cool it seems like a 3D
object so the v-board system is doing
some pretty sophisticated things
actually not only is it taking my data
which is is pretty intensive data the
all the 3D data and the texture and it's
sending it over the wire to Harry it's
doing some interesting things like
extending the reach of my arm so that
it's registering correctly on his
projection of the board that we are
sharing so we actually have some 3D
cameras here so that's why we actually
get here yeah now Harry didn't call call
it out but these are the connect 2
sensors that you can get now for
research purposes that are using
technology developed by various groups
at Microsoft research in collaboration
with the product groups so this is a map
of Seattle Center and our job of course
is to figure out how can we create that
smooth video how do we do that
reconstruction and there's been lots of
work in this over the years so if we
look at the images here that are SC this
is just a sampling of course of the
images and if we look at these there's
really a very when we look at just the
path that Harry took it's a very very
Jagged path that he took around Seattle
Center I mean he was probably on his
phone at the same time I'm not quite
sure but it makes our job as researchers
very difficult in reconstructing the
video and and reconstructing the
locations of the cameras to give a
smooth video but using some of this new
technology what we do is there's there's
three aspects that are happening here
the first thing we do is we try to
compute a smooth path that doesn't
deviate Too Much from the path that
Harry
took the next thing we need to do is
then of course figure out what is the
motion and we get that we get the
structure from the motion from Pixel to
pixel correlation uh are you understand
are you getting this Harry no I'm trying
to keep this simple for you har bring
this up no I it just it doesn't it just
doesn't sound right you know so so let
me uh also you know point out so the
clearly this this Gap here say your my
original pass and your SM the PA they
the they actually differ how can you
actually get get those those the new new
images that looks really smooth so it's
really an optimization problem what we
are doing here which is different from
all other stabilization techniques that
have been done before is we actually
take a a series of frames that are near
a particular uh proxy frame and we use
those to generate a synthetic image so
we are not when you watch that video
before uh and I I'll show it in a second
when you're watching that video you were
not seeing seeing the actual frames that
we captured you were seeing synthetic
frames that are filled in in between the
main frames
here these synthetic frames are very
carefully calculated to not deviate from
their neighbors so that we can get a
view that doesn't have you know blacked
out pixels we can't create information
where there isn't information but we
really can create a new view of the
world that is much easier for people to
consume because we're really talking
about tons and tons of data as we have
these sensors these ambient sensors the
question arises how do we make this data
consumable how do we make it something
that really shares the moments of our
lives and really wonderful ways does
that help it all yeah I I think I still
need to go back to read those uh
structure from motion papers and
including my own yes that would be great
thanks then thanks for giving us an
opportunity to showare it great great
thanks a lot yeah thank you I really
appreciate
yeah I think this Vision thing is really
uh really good you know I'm glad I
actually learned something and in CMU
and in Microsoft research so that
actually takes me to the last demo I
actually want to show you and I kind of
feel nowaday any kind of research
presentation uh will not be complete
without talking about artificial
intelligence and machine learning
especially deep learning and I was
asking pet and the Janet I said why
people so excited about deep learning to
me it seems like shallow learning is
more important I actually don't have
time to do deep learning but said no no
no no no you don't get it it's actually
about the technology that's called Deep
learning I say so I really want to show
you a demo that is actually about the
the the lot of focus the work we have in
Microsoft research about the building
computational infrastructure that will
enable all those deep learning machine
learning algorithms to be developed uh
so that we actually have the opportunity
to really have the state of art
recognition engines for practic i al
anything so to help me out I'm going to
have my colleague Johnson to come up to
the stage and talk about it Johnson
thank you
Harry good morning everybody um one of
the great things about working at
Microsoft is we're given opportunity to
work on really disruptive projects um 18
months ago we formed a small team to
work on an ambitious scalable
infrastructure structure for deep
learning that project called Adam is
both disruptive and we had a lot of fun
along the
way we
could I could stand here and talk about
all the disruptive things that uh we
think that Adam means um I could talk
about the fact that it's twice as
accurate 50 times faster than the uh
state of the art published State ofth
art or we could even even brag about the
fact that we've used atom to train
models DNN models of more than 40
billion connections and it's still
scaling
linearly but
instead I think we should just have fun
um and having fun means sharing some of
the stories that uh We've accumulated
throughout this
development So Adam is the official code
name but whenever we have
researchers and interns joining the
project they're surprised to find that
the code base is all called BFG right so
for people who wasted a lot of time in
the early 90s playing Doom we know what
BFG means um we call it BFG internally
because the
awesomeness the power and the Mystery of
the
system and let me tell you a little bit
about some of the engineers that helped
build the system one of my Engineers
utaka had uh was kind of stuck in uh
some of the networking work so as you
start dealing with 10 gig uh 40 gig
networking you're bound to hit some kind
of
bottlenecks and suddenly around November
of last
year we hit on this great idea on how to
remove all those bottlenecks to help
with the
asynchrony but we don't want to disrupt
our old system so we scheduled an MSR
cluster over the Christmas
break and how we decided to prove
whether our system works or not the this
new uh algorithm is we said let's see if
we can
break the current minute sort
record so we worked uh throughout the uh
Christmas
break and on Christmas Eve we broke the
record right by two times the speed of
the current minute sort
record so those are the types of fun
real senior Engineers
have and to just to show ourselves that
this system actually works in real life
we decided to build a Hello World app
our first app would be a dog breed
detector we we have
Javier um our great developer do it
while he was uh watching the Mexico
Netherland gra game on
Univision
um so in between the first goal of uh do
Santos and the subsequent loss were
yells cheers banging and at the end he
came out with the app the app is done
unfortunately Mexico lost
um so that's how we have
fun um today I'd like to Showcase you
the app that jaier built by using it on
actual live dogs just to Delight
you
so we'd like to start with
cowboy um who we think should easily be
identified by
Adam Adam what dog breed is
this me
TR Adam what dog breed is
this so Cortana is not
cooperating okay I'll have a talk with
I'll have a talk with Cortana
later
so Adam thanks
that cowboy domination thank you Cowboy
or life demos it's a lot of
pressure
oh my so we thought about using a
different dog this time a little bit
more
challenging let's see if Cortana behaves
this
time Cortana what kind of dog is
this could you take a picture for
me anyone care to guess what breed of
dog this
is ridgeback let's see if Cortana agrees
with
you I believe this is a Rhian ridgeback
wow
than thank
you now now's the real challenge anybody
care to guess what breed of dog
dooodle lab dooodle
okay let's see
what Adam
says I believe this is a
terrier So Adam thinks a terrier some
people thinks it's a
Labradoodle actually n is uh is actually
an Australian cboard dog so actually
you're both correct or partially correct
because net is made up of five
breeds um Labrador Retriever a poodle a
cocker spaniel Irish water spaniel and
an Irish
Terrier thank you Ned thanks thanks
Ned just to make sure that uh Adam is
all working correctly we will now try it
on a real human
being Cortana what breed a dog is
this could you take a picture for
me this probably RIS I will be the
target yeah risky and career limiting
but let's
go I believe this is not a oh oh my
goodness thank thank you
Johnson I I will have to tell my
kids I'm sure they worried more worried
than
me it's just the live demo is always
tricky and uh uh as you can imagine we
probably rehearsed a little bit and uh
the the interesting thing I would say
the it's just such a difficult problem
and is just a lot more to do I would
challenge Johnson and the team that you
know next time they take a picture of me
they would say it's not a dog it's a
horse uh because by chines zodiac I'm
actually a horse if they can get that
then I would say that's really
intelligent uh I'd like to finish my
presentation uh by summarizing you know
a few things that actually I believe is
important for MSR to move forward uh the
first thing I would say we are Microsoft
research and we research something new
something new in by ourselves and with
our in as with the academic Community I
want to take this opportunity once again
to thank you all of you for coming over
here and joining us you know for faculty
Summit I think a lot more we can work
together the second thing I would say
you know throughout of the 20 some years
of history and Microsoft research I
think we gradually figured out the the
right way to mix the product impact and
know one particular way to do that is
actually deploy our codes our systems
into production and we learn and iterate
it's very very important that uh we not
only have the initial ideas and
algorithms we actually try out on the
real data and will continue to improve
likely we'll see even more interesting
ideas along the way and we can do
that the third thing is actually we have
to really think about at this time for
Microsoft Corporation you know how we
can really lead the entire company to
together with our product partners and
with business groups to really think
hard you know what are the few next big
things that not only we can identify but
we can actually really invest enough uh
to really think about when the next wave
of uh Innovation and the technology
breakthrough comes in we actually have
the opportunity to really make a great
impact know whether this is really fpg
board whether it's know you know
different way of using the the the cloud
data you know we have to really think
hard
I think in the end you know when we run
a company and there are three things
that actually matters uh that is the
technology that the product and
experience that is a business and then
together with our product teams with our
business groups Microsoft research is in
a fantastic position to deliver a lot of
value to not only our company but to the
academic community and to the industry
thank you very much and welcome
again
so we have time for a few
questions about the process of moving
you can use the mic yeah okay um I
wonder about the process of moving from
research to
production and I'm aware of an
incubation process proc that used to be
true of
Microsoft and more recently something
called flight which I think is a testing
process that's on the Bing side and I
wonder were those examples of the
research and is research and Innovation
and this process only happening from
your research lab or were those actually
happening in other parts of the company
how how formal is this process it's a
it's it's a great question excellent the
question the question is really about
you know what is the process in
Microsoft research and in Microsoft
Corporation we actually really you know
transfer a lot of Technology from the
research side to the the product side
and uh you know pet and Genet can tell
you more know how we actually do this in
the company I also had some experience
when I was in Microsoft research here in
Redmond and also in Asia uh there are
different models we have tried and uh if
you think about that know we do have
this very large portfolio in Microsoft
of research we do a lot of very
theoretical you know fundamental
research things uh look at Les work for
instance and a lot of things and very
very theoretical to start with and uh
you know we we need to be thought for
that those things you know nice theories
you know people can study but not
necessarily you know technology
immediately can be applicable to the
product site but we do have some process
there and the the fact that we actually
move to more and the more you know the
web based you know services and that
makes it a lot of easier for us as well
and I point out a couple of things you
know what we really do one is actually
you know we do have the process of
engaging in all different kind of
product groups and we understand that
their planning cycle you know when they
actually do the next version of the
windows you know what kind of
Technologies they actually are looking
at they would they like to invest you
know what we already have in Microsoft
research I think we plan jointly with
the product s and we say you know can we
actually move those things over there
and the other thing is really you know
if you look at that you say you know
anytime you know the product people
might have some you know very difficult
challenges you know one of the latest
the greatest example I I I Learned was
actually when Xbox team they actually
had some challenges with the cameras and
it was very close to the shipping time
they reach out to Microsoft research
they say Jette can you actually help us
out and then we solicit you know some of
our experts who can actually immediately
take that on and do those things uh I
think overall I would say we have had a
great relationship you know between
Microsoft research and the various
product teams uh the challenge for us
moving forward is actually how can we
think about those significant areas you
know in the form maybe of projects that
we can really lead the way that you know
think ahead of the product Partners
let's say 18 months later I believe this
particular product line might need
something that is very very important I
just give you the random example in
interesting things say you know we we
are very clear about our strategy Cloud
first it basically means that we will
have you know global data centers as we
deploy so many servers the cost is going
to be an issue you know how should we
think about you know reducing the cost
not only today but also two three five
years later what are those Trends is
this fpga is this Optical networking so
those areas are where we can show a lot
of thought leadership and we are working
hard at
that hi Harry this is Renee great uh
idea the personal assistant I'm thinking
that many of the things could be useful
for determining conflicts in assigning
papers in conferences I wonder if there
are any plans to put that into
CMT oh I I I I I'm not sure that's thank
you very much it's such a such a great
question and uh oh by the way I hope
you're enjoying the World Cup soccer and
uh I I I think it's possible I think
it's possible but we we we really have
to work together with the academic
Community you know get the data I think
personal assistant is here to stay it's
more practical than I even ever thought
about I the part of that is basically
speech is really making great progress
last few years and not only us but the
entire industry is making great progress
there the second is actually people are
more and more willing and about know
sharing the personal data as long as we
actually show a lot of respect for the
Privacy uh it's still tricky but it's
actually definitely doable uh if you
think about those other applications you
know what the Catana can do what this
Catana research assistant can do um
that's where we actually would like to
you know collaborate with all of you and
think about those interesting problems
as Darren said that we will have beta
out pretty soon but we need to really
look at the kind of data and the kind of
questions that we can
address uh yeah the the the signing
paper reviewing paper is definitely one
of the most important things and I
always told my students when I was still
in research I said it's all about how
well you can write your
abstract and uh at the best of the
extended exract abstract in one page you
know why because this reviewers only
have enough time to look at that when
they go to
bathroom that's the only time they
really have they would decide that when
they no in bathroom whether they can
understand what you're talking about
that's my personal experience it doesn't
mean you
know
yeah oh we actually have a question
actually uh uh streaming uh streamed to
hear you said you mentioned the more
personalized
Computing is the future but there must
be many privacy issues associated with
that what research did you have and it's
happening in security and privacy uh
related to personal
Computing uh it's such a big question
and such an important
question I really appreciate in know
Craig M's uh uh called to action uh more
than a decade ago and when Bill was
still in the company and uh when Craig
actually started this trustworthy
Computing initiative in Microsoft at
that time very few people uh not only in
the industry even in Academia were not
paying enough attention as we get into
this new uh personal Computing error
with so many different uh personal
devices uh it's imperative for both the
users and all the companies actually
making software and the services to pay
significant attention to this issue of
privacy security is an issue that I
would say most of people think they
actually get it but the Privacy is
actually an issue at least in in my own
interaction with many customers of
Microsoft privacy is actually an issue
people still kind of don't really
understand what it actually means I
think we at Microsoft do a lot of
research in both security and the
Privacy fields and we actually take a
very strong view about the respecting
users the the privacy and we actually
would like to get the users permissions
for the data we actually would like to
do and you look at that you you don't
really even need to go too far but just
notice the reent uh uh there a lot of
you know pressed reaction know when
people learned uh in this academic paper
published by Facebook and they say wow
you know know how how can you do this
kind of research you know uh without
explicit consent from the users I think
it's actually a very complicated issue
and I actually uh encourage you to read
a couple of Articles coming from imsr
researchers particularly I think you
know if you have a chance to talk to
Duncan Wass Duncan has a very thoughtful
piece talking about that you know the
world is moving on you know we need to
understand that the data will be
everywhere and you may or may not even
know you actually have your personal
data in number of devices and those
service providers and they actually have
good intention to actually help you like
in the case of Catana that if you are
willing to give a little bit of personal
information the Kotana can actually help
you but it needs to be a dialogue needs
to be a dialogue between the user and
the service provider and it needs to be
thoughtful and this is where I actually
think Microsoft research and the
academic research Community can work
together and to lead the way uh it
actually makes people a little bit
uncomfortable whenever they think about
privacy but we have to face this issue
and we have to be explicit and there
could be some incredible technology
breakthroughs there uh but we have to
work together it's a very challenging
issue and I don't want to take light of
that and I look forward to having the
opportunity to actually collaborate with
many of you and to work on those tough
issues thank you
great stuff there an amazing talk by
Harry Shum there and I'm happy to say
that Harry will soon be joining us right
here in the hood for an online exclusive
interview so more to come go nowhere
he'll be joining us right here on set
and that is just one of our many online
only extras so bonus for you for joining
us here thanks for being here after
visiting with Harry we're going to
launch into our live research in Focus
interviews we got a lot of them for you
great information today we're going to
learn how Computing is helping to make
the world better from improving the
quality of life for people with
paralysis to monitoring Africa's
Wildlife to realizing the promise of
online education we'll also get a look
at some amazing devices that are pushing
the limits of miniaturization and we'll
talk with researchers who are using our
neural and physiological responses to
combat distracted driving and reduce the
number of bugs in computer programs but
just not at the same time of course in
writing code while driving could be
pretty distracting even with a
hands-free device that's why I don't
write code because I I got so much
driving to do that's of course the
reason now look while we're waiting for
Harry to make his way over here from the
Kodiak room to where we are in the hood
room here we're going to go to our field
correspondent Josephine Chang Josephine
what is the reaction of the crowd there
to the keynote you know they were very
receptive but I got to say the biggest
applause was not necessarily for Harry
but for the dogs the really cute dogs
that were out here you know project Adam
was able to identify a Dalmatian really
really quickly and even a more
complicated breed like a Rhian ridgeback
I don't think I could have done that it
had a little bit bit of trouble with the
FI dog you know which was everybody
guessed I mean it guessed a terrier and
everybody guessed something else and
then of course the crowd just went nuts
and laughed when uh they tried to
identify Harry as a dog and said no not
a dog but but seriously I think that uh
Harry made a lot of great points um one
of them that people responded to was the
fact that what is the next big Frontier
it is not about the power of computing
we already have very extremely powerful
computers it's not really about storage
it's almost un limited storage these
days it's really about human interaction
in other words how do we as humans you
know access and deploy and interact with
all the technologies that will be around
us all the time so that was really
interesting times for Microsoft research
and see it'll be interesting to see how
far they get in hitting this very high
bar that they set for themselves and you
know after Harry's speech of course
there was the presentation of the
Microsoft faculty research Awards and
this is sort of the annual ual tradition
of recognizing the most promising young
stars in computer science research and
one of this year's winners is with me
now this is Roxanna Jam Basu from
Columbia University congratulations
thank you so much I want you to tell us
what does winning this award mean to you
what is the significance of it oh it's
it's an amazing uh an amazing thing I'm
very humbled and very grateful for this
award uh it's very highly recognized as
a very prestigious award uh and so you
know what it means for me of course is
great recognition for my work as well as
uh um you know extremely interesting
opportunities for collaborating with
researchers in the future of course
there is the you know cash side of
things which is going to help enormously
in my uh research in boost shopping uh
further my team of students and funding
them uh you know to do great projects
which would be great and your research
concerns something that I think more
more people are are interested in which
is privacy in our on online world what
is uh what is your research showing and
what will it allow people to do mhm
right so uh you know I work uh in
privacy right I try to kind of restore a
little bit of the Privacy that we are
kind of uh um losing more and more in
this data driven World um so you know
today a lot of web services a lot of
mobile applications accumulate a lot of
information about us every location
every search that we make um uh emails
Etc right and they use it for a variety
of purposes like ads for example ads but
also very good things right Harry sham
also talked about leveraging data right
to personalize the assistant you know
the the the research assistant which is
a great example of you know Wonderful
uses of the data right um and uh but of
course there are there is also the
possibility of data misuse well one day
I think I think your research is going
to be very important it'll allow us to
to not only know what how we're being
targeted by ads but also how we can
access further information again
congratulations on the faculty award and
enjoy the rest of the summit thank you
Chris fact to
you Josephine thank you as promised here
on the hood set Harry Shum is here and I
concur with Cortana I believe you not a
terrier I believe I guess I'm not I was
really worried very impressive stuff
obviously as you said demoing live can
always be nerve-racking but really cool
stuff we're going to talk about that and
with all the amazing work going on at
Microsoft research how did you decide
how did you narrow down what you wanted
to demo today wow this is actually
really hard it's I actually thought L on
the heart when I prepared
uh my presentation today it's kind of
like you know you asking know which
children you like more than others uh I
actually picked three very interesting
uh research projects to start with today
and uh especially you know the first two
that I had the opportunity to learn
recently after I had a chance to uh work
with MSR again so those two are uh the
quantum Computing which is really
exciting new breakthrough you know
happening right now and also the
economics and computation this is
actually not only about the computer
science but also economics and the
business model something that at the
Microsoft uh we absolutely think a lot
about it now from your talk this morning
your opening keynote there it sounds
like the Microsoft research agenda is
very much in line with the company's
Vision did one influence the other well
at the Microsoft research we always had
this opportunity to work very closely
with not only our engineering leaders
but also our business Business Leaders
uh as the uh SAA said you know after he
took uh CEO role that you know we work
as one Microsoft we work together think
about you know what should be the
business model we are getting into what
should be the product and the experience
that we built what kind of Technologies
we have in the company in particular you
know what kind of Technology we have
from Microsoft research we can leverage
so I would say we're actually very happy
you know working very closely across the
company
now Peter Lee brought you out on stage
and before you came out he talked about
uh the emotions behind the research and
what you guys are doing and I wrote down
he wrote exhilaration and Terror he
admits that Terror was a big part of it
because you want to deliver so talk
about the responsibility of Microsoft
research and what you feel maybe that
responsibility is to the scientific
community at large yeah as as a good
student I always say Professor is always
right I'm sure Peter is right I think I
would say you know the excitement is
definitely there uh if if you look at
the new change across the company with
SAA uh replacing Steve balber as our new
CEO uh the the a couple of examples I
mentioned in my speech you know the big
change for the company you know with the
big change for the company from the
business model to our strategic Focus
areas it absolutely will have the
significant impact on Microsoft research
I would say it's more about
opportunities and uh know that whether
or not we can actually to capture
speaking of opportunities you know
looking down the road what are you most
excited about or or what do you think is
the most compelling looking down the
road with the research being done
Microsoft I I would say I I actually uh
tried tried to uh hypothesize a few
areas where we believe the next big
things will happen you know I did talk
about you know census everywhere I did
talk about the I used the example the
the the vboard example talking about the
MB and intellig
and I talked a little bit about the the
the excitement in Ai and machine
learning um if you if you say Harry
there's only one thing why don't you
tell us one thing I would say know
ambient intelligence is something that
we feel so excited in the company with
the the
the the right products know coming out
of Microsoft with the new strategy you
know our CE outlined I see tremendous
opportunities to push things like you
know the
Catana understanding the the users by
aggregating and a lot of Contex
information about the user in a very
respectful way and know know think deep
about the Privacy yet providing you know
very useful experience for the user help
the user to get the stuff done uh it's
just tremendous excitement I think you
know for Microsoft research talk about
again going back to to Peter's reference
of Terror talk about you know behind the
scenes what it's like when you when we
get to see and hear things like ortana
unveiled and we to see it you go wow I
can't believe what it just did you know
paraded dogs out there recognize that's
amazing but what about uh you know all
of the research leading up to that all
of the you know the the probably
tripping points in the roadblocks and
and how difficult is it to get to this
point I I would say you know that
suddenly you know we we need to have a
view where is the world is heading and
if we truly believe in that view then we
you know make sure that you know we have
double down our investment there uh when
you actually double down your investment
there then you will have the sense of
responsibility saying you know are we
making the right bets and you know are
we making big enough bets uh it's going
to be you know very exciting and you
know any kind of you know big
initiatives big research projects
there's always this room for failure in
fact that we embrace the failure um when
we do any kind of research projects is
nothing is guaranteed but I would say
the best way to predict the future is
creating our own that's how we think
about this in Microsoft research that's
very well put absolutely and then
obviously it's been a very special year
several researchers receiving
significant honors including lesli
lamort the touring award you mentioned
earlier uh what do you think attracts uh
brilliant scientists to Microsoft Beyond
just the obvious obviously
accomplishments achievements get you
more attention but why do you think it's
become just such an undeniable
Powerhouse with Microsoft I I I just
speech I'm just speechless and as I
think about the the incredible you know
brain power and the great minds we have
uh in Microsoft research I joined the
Microsoft uh in the Microsoft research
18 years ago uh I still remember my own
excitement the first week uh I went to
my office I remember I called my wife I
said you cannot believe this Jim bling
is only three offices down my hallway
yeah and few office the further is
actually Jim kajia those were incredible
names in computer Graphics as a young
researcher myself when I joined the
Microsoft research you know that was the
draw that was the draw to work with the
greatest Minds in our field and we have
been very fortunate to have build a
Microsoft research as a Powerhouse and
we we we we are very confident we will
continue to educate the next generation
of Greater computer scientists I with
names like lesie Lamport Chuck Zer and I
think it's it's just a inspiring it's
just inspiring to have this younger
generation you know join join Force it's
not only just for Microsoft research
it's not even just for Microsoft
Corporation it's it's for our industry
it's for our society uh the future is
upon us you know we just have to be bold
that's fun to hear you talk about day
one for you and I can't believe what I'm
involved in and how neat is it for you
here this is the 15th annual faculty
Summit that's to see the the the room
full of people to see so much curiosity
obviously there's a lot of Brilliant
Minds here hundreds hundreds of the
brightest but there's also just a lot of
curiosity people inspired walking up and
down the hall it's got to be pretty
satisfying to see what this has become
uh not just scientifically but kind of
culturally right that's that's very true
uh thank you for this particular
question and I I actually want to take
this opportunity to thank all those
people in Academia that we have had the
opportunity to partner with to
collaborate with you know whether
projects with their students and uh
whether they spend some time visiting us
here or we visit them I think the great
thing about the research Community is
that we learn from each other and in a
very amicable way and know we write the
papers we read the papers and we learn
from them and we challenge each other uh
it's just fascinating to see the the old
friends and new friends coming here to
attend the faculty Summits and uh um we
we thank them for their partnership you
know and we want to continue this great
relationship with the Academia and the
scientific community and we can do more
together well har thank you thanks for
giving us a couple of a couple of extra
minutes after your keynot this morning
thanks for kind of leading things off
for us today this is a great way to kick
things off we appreciate it thanks a lot
all right enjoy the rest of the sumon as
well